foreign
ERS of President Jairo volsonaro
gathered in the streets a way to protest
the results of Sunday's presidential
election
the waiting for president bolsonaro to
tell them what to do they're convinced
Silva was selected president by
committing fraud
the election isn't over we want a third
round we're not going to give the
country to a thief so that we become
Venezuela he was sentenced to prison and
was freed by a friend
they have brought food to remain on the
roads but are still uncertain about what
to do next
truck drivers who support president jair
bolsonaro were blocking this road that
connects the capital Brasilia with other
parts of the country they were removed
by the police using tear gas this is an
example of the extreme polarization that
exists in this country and how there's
lots of people here that are not happy
with Sunday's results
there are roadblocks in several parts of
the country a close Ally of Lola Da
Silva compare them to Donald Trump's
supporters who try to take over U.S
Congress when Joe Biden won the
presidency
we want a military intervention because
we can't accept these results Lula is a
thief and he should be in prison
on Monday there was little activity at
the planaldo presidential Palace sonar
was there but chose once again not to
speak
the president's silence only adds up to
the tension that has prevailed
throughout the electoral process his
sons who are members of Congress
expressed their support for their father
on Twitter one of them wrote that I am
with you for whatever is coming next
[Applause]
but while the incumbent president
remains quiet
president-elect Lola Da Silva has
already started planning his cabinet and
talking to leaders around the world
including a meeting with Argentina's
president Alberto Fernandez
analysts say one of his top priorities
should be ending the depolarization that
exists in this country today
it is clear that this final result shows
a divided country divided regionally
divided between the states that makes up
the Brazilian Federation and a division
within society and even among families
which make the first task of the new
president-elect to seek to establish an
agenda proposal to reduce this political
polarization
has two months left in office everyone
is waiting to hear what he has to say
about the election
and whether his message will bring
reconciliation of South further
divisions within Brazilian Society
lucania Brazil